on the pitch at hand cross primary
there's a lot to cheer about england won
two new versus zero
journey when they did that pass to
mullah
i was like this oh no and then and then
but luckily you missed and i was like
this oh my god
yes
[Music]
but here they don't remember the years
of hurt that chris does
and the frustration of fans who can't
get to games abroad
when you've got the die hard england
fans i've got a few friends actually
that go
to home and away games for them not to
be able to go this time i really feel
for them
because they invest a lot of time and a
lot of money to go and watch
like england and now they're being told
they're not allowed to and i just don't
think that's fair
is coming home this time of course he's
coming home i have to say it's coming
home
because what's the point of me doing
this if i didn't believe it right if an
england fan wanted to go to italy they'd
have to be tested before
during and after their journey they'd
have to quarantine in italy and back
here
in the uk which means they might miss
the semi-final and the final at wembley
if we keep winning
as the fa grapple with the trappings of
a pandemic they stopped selling tickets
to fans in england through their normal
channels i'm an
england fan i've been living in rome for
about 28 years but what that does mean
is more for those already abroad i
had no idea that i'd be able to watch
england play this this
this tournament um and then this morning
i woke up to the news that expats could
kind of do whatever they could to fill
themselves up with tickets
um and now you know i don't want to be
too hopeful but i could be
i can watch the team as they march
onwards
to gloria hopefully but at least onwards
as the players prepare for their euros
semi-final
at home they'll be cheered on from afar
from a country
hoping that this time it could really be
england's year
ali sky news